days away from being born when you were
here yeah how is he doing
how old is he now he's 14 months a year
yeah how is he what's he like he's
walking running he's funny he's very
funny he laughs at everything like I do
he laughs at my jokes yeah I'm you know
what I always omits very self-centered
but if someone laughs is something I do
I just say oh they have a great sense of
humor but I realize it's a very
self-centered thing to say yeah oh that
kid gets it so so okay no more like I'll
criticize like my husband's shirt am i
honey really we're wearing that and my
son goes sounds like your kid has a
little cigar to my son you nail them now
I tell me about it Grand Hotel yeah you
wear many hats yeah you're directing
you're producing you're acting all of
this while having a 14 month old son
well no this well you did this a while
ago even earlier so yeah it was eight
weeks old what'd you bring this with an
eight week old yeah and I was
breastfeeding on set and sleeping three
hours but we actually have a picture
here I took no I'm sorry I did not take
the head picture I heard you were
breastfeeding so I took a photo no there
was a photo of you directing and
breastfeeding at the same time and I
thought that's incredible I mean that
that's just an amazing thing to be able
to do
yeah I have so many videos of me going
and action and the explosions should be
bigger yeah it wasn't that we were doing
a stunt where a guy gets hit by a car
and I'm like harder but yeah it was fun
it was fun I almost feel like this baby
is going to grow up knowing how to
direct because just you know being
suckling and hearing you dork yeah I
could say suckling I mean you did yeah
feeding I don't know seeing is probably
a little makes it sound less barnyard
[Laughter]
[Applause]
apologize that was insane anyway so the
babies they're suckling and but I would
just think that that would be first of
all nice to have Santiago with you on
the set yeah just like a nice to be on
the set and feel like you're working and
being a mom at the exact same time I
mean women do it every day yeah I mean
I'm I'm lucky I'm in an industry that
allows me to do it you know he if I'm in
the office he's in the office if I'm on
set he's on set if I'm that's where is
it distracting for the actors if they're
if you're trying to talk to them and
you're breastfeeding is that a problem I
don't care but no that's good that's
fair you do have to normalize it like
women breastfeed yeah I like let's
normalize motherhood mom yeah
not the actor the actors of granite are
amazing but like the extras where I had
to like direct them so I was
breastfeeding and one guy wouldn't do
when I was like you got to tell that guy
he's got a cross and then and then we do
a take I hate that guy go tell him he
needs to and I'm breastfeeding so if I
get up and I go you need to cry you need
to move okay
and the guy was like I don't even know
where to look I forgot I was Santiago's
like come on I'm trying to eat here and
you're ruining it like dinnertime I have
really distilled your son into this